[Music]
you are nine years old yes yes you are
so when did you first meet Johnny
Knoxville and a movie called fun-sized
he did teach me a lot of bad stuff he
taught you bad stuff Johnny Knoxville I
imagine he did what did he teach you
teach you to do that's bad I punch
people in the cookies before but he
taught me away better way to do it he
taught you as at the time you were what
eight he taught you how to punch people
o seven
well that's acceptable then he taught
you to hit people in the crotch he told
me to do it like this do it like that
cuz that would cause more pain and
damage exactly oh what a wonderful
lesson for a young boy to learn did you
know did you know about jackass did you
watch jackass you a fan that was like my
favorite thing I've ever seen right more
than like a sunset or a mountain you
don't even just mean movies and TV shows
you mean like that's your favorite thing
you've ever seen yeah but my favorite
part is when Johnny gets hit by balls
and bam gets dumped and snakes you like
that you like seeing adult men screaming
and getting badly hurt yes okay
do you think their stunts are smart do
you like when you look at it do you
think that's a smart thing to do is that
something you want to do when you get
older yes but it is very dumb to do
right but you said yes you still want to
do it yes oh so you're going to do that
later on in life is you're going to try
and and get hurt
yes okay I'm gonna try and talk you out
of that later because I'd like you to
make a nice kid and I don't want you to
be hurt you nice at you you're nice at
home you're nice at home and you're nice
on the set it's the other way around
I'm mean on the set and usually nice at
home okay and you do this on purpose but
this is just how you are it's never an
accident you walk around punching people
you know like for fun that's that's fun
for you you just punch people okay
it's called being a sociopath well yeah
we'll learn that lourd later I'm curious
what did you do for your bad grandpa
audition I do pee my pants like the two
guys at a picnic you had to pee your
pants next to two guys at a picnic yes
okay and how did that go
we got great reactions they got in
fights which I wanted to laugh but I
couldn't or I didn't get the part so you
kind of had to play it straight yeah
yeah all right well we have a clip here
from a beauty pageant Oh No yes where
they dressed you up as a little girl
well let's look at the clip first okay
we're going to look at this clip from
the beauty pageant and and yeah
when I ask some divine yeah good
everyone Lindsey dill
[Music]
[Applause]
people no not me those Lindsey dill that
was not you well I was just stopping
Lindsey dill but Lindsey don't dick
right I can't control indie deal right
I have a feeling this is all gonna end
up in a court proceeding I know yeah
oh he's nodding oh yeah oh yeah yeah
within the minor we are completely out
of time I did want to mention jackass
presents bad grandpa opens in theaters
on Friday and Jackson I wish good things
for you you seem like a well you're a
good guy you seem like a good guy